je pense je pense pas de georges s'est
surtout exprimé en français mais enfin
si il faut traduire un petit peu je
pense que j'en serai à peu près capable
je pense que ceci réduit même parce que
je veux dire d'ailleurs c'est comme ça
que nous sommes connus sur la terrasse
de roland garros locaux animeront une
émission sur les coulisses de ce tournoi
je pense que les deux se ressent
j'essaie dans les deux cas de mettre un
peu un peu de couleurs pense que je
pense que les deux les deux sens
bien sûr des regards nous nous sommes
connus sur l'été dernier sur fort boyard
je pense qu'elles sont elles sans signal
a eu droit aux bestioles et moi aussi
donc ça ça crée des sacrés délire